Ron chernow author of tighten the life
of john d rockefeller senior how would
you describe him rockefeller items
described by william james is most
strongly bad and strongly good human
being he had ever met I think that
probably expresses that as well as
anyone has ever expressed it he was a
man of such profound and baffling
contradictions and men who was
simultaneously the most ferocious of the
robber barons and the most farsighted of
the philanthropists and these two
seemingly disparate human beings were
rolled up inside one body in one mind
and that was really my task as the
biographer to try to make sense of the
two halves of this whole what
relationship is john d rockefeller
senior did senator Jay Rockefeller of
West Virginia Gregg grandfather okay
John D senior was the father of john d
rockefeller jr. whose sons were david
nelson at all and then john d
rockefeller the third who was the oldest
grandson of john d rockefeller is the
father of jay rockefeller and what in
our society would not be here without
the Rockefellers well I think the
significant thing about the Rockefellers
is that they were great institution
builders that john d rockefeller not
only created Standard Oil which was the
largest business empire on earth but he
created the most extensive philanthropic
empire that includes what is today the
University of Chicago Spelman College
Rockefeller University University
Rockefeller Foundation and I think that
he has cast such a long shadow because
he created these permanent corporate
forms both in the business world in the
philanthropic world and I should say
Ryan that in terms of the business
empire
although the Standard Oil Trust was
broken up by the Supreme Court in 1911
to give you some idea of the size of
that trust when it was dismantled in
1911 the heirs included today
Exxon Mobil amico Chevron Conoco Arco BP
America Chesebrough pons and two dozen
other companies so I don't know that the
business world has ever seen an
agglomeration of wealth
power on the scale of standard oil this
is the last picture you have in the book
people are fascinated by Rockefellers
face you could see their house seamed
and lined and and leathery it was and
you could also see in that photo that he
was a more thoughtful man than people
realized a more philosophical and this
was one of the real surprises for me
during the bug that he was the most
mysterious and reclusive of the robber
barons but I found in going through his
papers that he had spent an enormous
amount of time analyzing what he was
doing squaring his behavior often his
bad behavior which Chief Chris didn't
see his bad behavior squaring it with
his conscience and his creator and
elaborating a theory of Monopoly that
enabled him to do what he did filled
with a messianic and self-righteous
sense of absurdity there's a photo here
with the former governor of New York
Nelson Rockefeller who else is in that
photo okay Nelson is holding his eldest
son Rodman in the middle you have john d
rockefeller senior to the left john d
rockefeller jr. nelson was the first of
the grandchildren to have a son and
nelson very much identified with his
grandfather he revered his grandfather
and so he felt that he was very much the
standard bearer in that generation of
the family even though he was the the
second son he had a brave kind of
nudging his older brother out of the
limelight
incidentally Nelson and JD are senior
were born on the same day which Nelson
took is a very important sign of the
fact that he was destined to carry on
the family tradition Howell was
Rockefeller senior john d rockefeller
when he died he was nearly 98 and in
fact in the early 1900's he announced
that he planned to live to the age of
100 and one thing about john d
rockefeller when he set his mind to
doing something he had an extraordinary
ability to focus his mind on goals and
he almost always achieved them so that
he was nearly 98
he died so he very nearly made good on
his boast that he would live 200 and he
became something of a new-age health
fanatic and he had all sorts of theories
in terms of how he could prolong his
life
for instance this was the bane of his
luncheon companions but he used to chew
food ten times before swallowing and
guests who observed him closely said
that even when he had had liquid in his
mouth he would swirl or sift at ten
times before swallowing and what it
meant was that people who were
absolutely thrilled to be invited to the
luncheon table of the world's richest
men found themselves after 20 minutes
finished with their own food and for the
next hour watching John Dee finish his
well maybe there was something to this
masticating of the of the food because
he very nearly lived to a hundred you
know in one of the earlier books we did
with Linda Simon on William James so you
mentioned early in your remarks he
fashioned something that William
Gladstone had done stewing food
thirty-two times every time he ate what
is this business of counting the number
of times you chew in that time of the
world actually I think that there was
kind of an old wives tale at the time
that the more you masticated the food
and soaked it with saliva that the
easier it would be to digest bracha felt
when he was in his early 50s after he
had created his global oil monopoly had
a kind of breakdown it was both a
physical and nervous breakdown of sorts
and he had terrible digestive problems
it's very very interesting because the
source of that breakdown when he was in
his early 50s was not as one might
imagine the stress and strain of
creating Standard Oil it was the strain
of his charitable commitments
particularly he was creating the
University of Chicago at the time so he
began a diet of bread and crackers in
order to cure these digestive problems
what happened was that there was a whole
very pernicious mythology for the rest
of his life
that he could only survive on mother's
milk I mean this was part of this
vampirish image of Rockefeller that he
was such a ghoulish character that he
needed mother's milk in order to survive
Rockefeller who had very
a little concern for public opinion
really never bothered to disabuse the
public or the the press of the fact that
he ate normally and he ate whatever he
wanted but throughout his life he ate
very sparingly which is one reason that
people remember him not as this rather
range a young man who created Standard
Oil
but this spindly wizened little guy
hopping around on the golf course or
mugging in front of the the newsreel
cameras he finally waved around ninety
pounds by the time he died what got you
interested in this subject
well actually Random House asked me to
write about john d rockefeller after i
finished my book on the Warburg's and i
must confess to my embarrassment i
thought it was an absolutely ghastly
idea because i had done these family
sagas and i was very eager to do a pure
biography which i thought would be more
compact and cohesive and i told my
editor at Random House and got off that
I thought that Rockefeller was the worst
subject imaginable like that he just
seemed to me cold wouldn't mechanical
ruthless a man without any interior life
that I could say and she suggested that
I visit a place called the Rockefeller
archive center that was set up by the
family which is run by a team of
independent archivists and it was a
strange day that I spent there because I
was almost trying to wriggle out of the
the project and I told the archive
director that I really was not
interested in Rockefeller because he had
no voice he didn't seem to have an inner
life and I said to him I don't hear the
music of his mind so how can I write a
biography about him and with that he
produced an interview that had been
privately conducted with Rockefeller
between 1917 and 1920 was part of what
was supposed to be an official biography
that was never finally published so
suddenly here was this man who had no
voice who was who was so reclusive and
secretive and I have a 1700 page
transcript where he's giving a
blow-by-blow account of every major
twist and turn of his career and I
suddenly at
point encountered a personality that I
hadn't encountered in any of the
previous Rockefeller biographies rather
than this cold mute reserved figure here
was someone who was fiery he was often
funny he was amazingly analytical in
fact he was quite brilliant
now I hasten to say he was often
sanctimonious I could see that there was
a lot of self delusion and
rationalization he evaded a lot of
questions about the most controversial
aspects of his life but I saw just how
much time he had privately invested into
analyzing what he had done and having
written for instance about JP Morgan who
at most could concentrate on something
for five minutes here was somebody who
had spent decades analyzing what he was
doing who had a brilliant strategic
sense of the of the oil industry and I
said to myself here is the fiery Titan
whom I had suspected must be lurking
somewhere inside Rockefeller but whom I
did not know for a certainty existed
because I had never seen any evidence of
it in the biographies that had been
written about him and the transcript you
talked about in the interview was
William Angliss William Inglis right
from and every morning before
Rockefeller golfed Rockefeller was
summoned but did the exact same things
at the exact same times every day so
right before they went out on the golf
course every day Inglis would interview
Rockefeller for a half an hour to an
hour Rockefeller would recline on a
couch with his eyes closed very often
his English was reading the question to
him Rockefeller appeared to be dozing
and then Rockefeller would suddenly snap
his eyes open and give a very precise
answer the structure to that interview
must be unique in American economic
history if not history as general
because what Inglis did he took the
writings of Rockefellers two most famous
muckraking critics Henry Demarest Lloyd
and most notably Ida Tarbell
and actually read paragraph by paragraph
code to Rockefeller the most scathing
charges against him so this was a
fascinating document having him actually
confront his most severe critics and it
was an extraordinary document as soon as
I saw that I knew that I wanted to write
the book and I knew that this was a rare
historical opportunity of taking someone
who was seemingly so familiar to the
public and saying to them he's
completely unfamiliar you really don't
know what he was like at all because he
didn't want to share it with anybody and
go back to the why did go back what I
want you to go back to the the Tarbell
articles that she wrote was a McClure's
magazine éclairs magazine from 1902 to
1905 because in your book you basically
suggest that those magazines the
articles led to the breakup of Standard
Oil or to the Sherman Antitrust Act they
had a powerful impact the articles were
coming out in in serial form which meant
that each issue of McClure's had a
larger circulation it kept jumping from
issue to issue also because it extended
over such a long period of time with
each new installment more Rockefeller
critics more rockefeller haters would
come out of the woodwork you know so
that the circle of sources kept a
growing with each issue and by an
extraordinary historical coincidence Ida
Tarbell was publishing this series just
as the man in the White House Teddy
Roosevelt was looking to single out a
single notorious trust for an antitrust
case in order to make an example of it
and it was really Ida Tarbell who turned
john d rockefeller into the most hated
man of the in the country and really
brought all of the evils of the Standard
Oil Trust to public attention just at
the moment when Teddy Roosevelt was not
only looking for you know a big brutal
rich unrepentant trust but one that the
public felt strongly about we have a
picture from the book and I had to ask
you because you've got a lot of pictures
in here where this comes from but this
is Ida Tarbell sure in your book how old
was she you know and when this picture
was taken yeah this picture she was she
would have been about 40 years old she's
sitting in the offices of McClure's
magazine you could see that she was not
only rather attractive person but that
she had tremendous dignity you could
actually see the the self-possession of
the woman there and it took tremendous
courage to take on Standard Oil in fact
her father
we've been an independent oilman crushed
by Standard Oil warned her that she
would that her life would be in danger
if she took on Standard Oil the strange
thing was Brian that you know far from
being crushed by standard Oilers she was
researching it this lady kept taking
shots at Standard Oil over three year
period and didn't take any fire in
return but Rockefeller mist was really
the two major things were going on in
American life one was the power of the
press because Ida Tarbell was able to
take on a subject much more complicated
slice open standard all dissected given
accurate chronology of it no previous
generation reporters had been able to
tackle such complicated issues and
Rockefeller also did not realize that
with Teddy Roosevelt power was migrating
from the legislative to the executive
branch and that for the first time the
federal government felt that it had the
both the right and the power to take on
the largest corporations in the in the
country and so that there was a very
powerful dialectic at work between Teddy
Roosevelt and the muckraking journalists
like Ida Tarbell and the combination
overwhelmed Rockefeller who felt that he
didn't need to dignify the series with
any response and it was a fatal mistake
he did not hire that is Standard Oil did
not hire it's for his publicist until
1906 a year after the Ida Tarbell series
ended today a corporate executive in
similar situation would probably have a
team of 30 or 40 public relations people
working around the clock Ida Tarbell
name comes up all through the Lincoln
books I mean she wrote a Lincoln book
that's often quoted in all the books
we've done here who was she
and how did she get interested in
Standard Oil and John rockefeller she
grew up in in western Pennsylvania in
the 1860s and 1870s at exactly the
moment when Standard Oil was taking over
first the refining industry then the
pipelines then the marketing and so john
d rockefeller in her childhood was a
legendary figure was really a bogeyman
all of her neighbors as she felt had
been ruined by Standard Oil particularly
her father so that this was a
who had a squirt settled with with
Standard Oil she went to work from
McClure's in the 1890s as I said she did
the biographical series on Lincoln that
was very good and mine on Napoleon that
was significant because when she came to
do the Standard Oil Series which she
started working on in 1901 she was
already accustomed to a kind of great
man approach to history which meant that
although her series was nominally
entitled the history of the Standard Oil
Company Standard Oil in the series is
synonymous with john d rockefeller now
rockefeller is no question was the
mastermind so he was the right one to
focus on but rockefeller operated by
consensus he had very very powerful
lieutenants like Henry Flagler and John
D Archbold you know men who were quite
tough and and corrupt who got off really
scot free in the Tarbell series because
having done Lincoln and and Napoleon she
realized that it had a very powerful
psychological effect on readers to focus
on one figure in particularly when
you're dealing with this gigantic
amorphous cartel called the Standard Oil
it makes the whole story so much more
compelling and dramatic to focus on one
man so that there's remarkably little
about Rockefellers very powerful
colleagues in the in this series so that
all of the public animosity that was
aroused by Ida Tarbell was directed at
one man that was john d rockefeller jr.
how long did it take you to write this
took about four or five years to do it
which is longer than I had worked on the
the previous books you know in my
naivete since I was doing a bog my
previous books had been family sagas I
thought that this would be more compact
and quicker but I quickly discovered is
that when you're writing about john d
rockefeller you don't feel like you're
writing about a human being you feel
like you're writing about a sovereign
state I mean had millions of documents
to use where do you live live in
Brooklyn Heights which is just across
the East River from the lower Manhattan
skyline within view of the DeMorgan Bank
which was the subject of my first book
and we live in a historic brownstone
from the 1840s which had actually been a
rooming house during the Civil War as
in rich history and we occupied the
module X of the brownstone were you able
to interview any living Rockefellers I
did I had a couple of very nice
conversations with with David
Rockefeller the the family was guarded
but cordial what's his relationship to
John Dee senior grandson in fact I'm
really an adored grandson and because
John Dee's senior lived so long David
Nelson Laurance and all the rest were
had graduated from college they had
married they had started in their
business careers and what David
Rockefeller said to me said she there's
so many things I wish that I had asked
grandpa I think what he didn't realize
is that grandpa studiously avoided
certain topics in fact when Nelson was a
senior at Dartmouth Nelson wanted to do
his senior thesis on Standard Oil and
vindicate grandpa against his critics he
wrote to his father john d rockefeller
jr. saying I so admire grandfather you
think you could arrange for me to speak
to him now most grandfathers would leap
at the opportunity to tell war stories
about their business career a few weeks
later letter comes back from his father
saying that grandfather has no desire to
talk about Standard Oil and I make much
of this in the book because in most
families is a very rich oral history
whereas the Rockefeller family is a
family that's riddled by strange
silences and taboos and I speculate in
the book and I'm almost certain I'm
right about this that john d rockefeller
jr. stimulated this three-year interview
that William a wingless did with his
father I think because William O inglis
reading aloud Henry Demarest Lloyd
reading aloud Ida Tarbell was able to
ask his father as John D senior all the
questions the chandi Jr had never been
able to ask because the whole subject
was too touching you could see John Dee
Rockville jr. actually monitoring and
secretly reading the transcripts from
this interview because when Tom Bell was
exposing john d rockefeller he didn't
sit down with his family and say let me
give you my version of events so that
you know what happened to
I want you to think happened he just
left this family in a very uncomfortable
silence where they were supposed to
believe in fathers integrity really is
an article of faith what is a trust a
trust actually a trust became synonymous
with monopoly and the psalmist used as a
shorthand for it today what happened
during the era of John Deere I fell
senior was that a corporation that was
located in one state was not able to buy
the stock in the corporation and the
corporation located another state so it
was very difficult to conduct an
interstate business which is why there
was a Standard Oil of New York and there
was a Standard Oil of New Jersey etc etc
the way that standard owed was able to
operate nationally was that the
individual shareholders would pass on
their stock to a group of trustees who
would then return to them trust
certificates so the trust was a way for
them to circumvent these legal
restrictions on operating interstate it
was a way of consolidating all the
companies in an industry and hence
became synonymous with monopolies itself
which is why it's called the Sherman
Antitrust Act we still knew the term
still survives and the term antitrust so
if we were to find john d rockefeller
senior at his worst moment or as defined
by somebody like Ida Tarbell where was
he where was he located and what was he
doing that made everybody so mad okay
you Rockefeller was notorious from the
time that he was a young man I mean we
have to remember that the oil industry
like the computer industry today was
created by young men which is often the
case with new industries and after
kernel had been Drake struck oil in
Titusville Pennsylvania in 1859 there
was a wild rip-roaring gold rush'
atmosphere wasn't the kind of thing that
you know all settled people rushed off
to monster western Pennsylvania it was
all of these young guys who had just
been demobilized
after the Civil War rockefeller created
Standard Oil in Cleveland in 1870 he
quickly realized that the most
significant factor
in the competitive rush to dominate a
way it was going to be transportation
because basically one company's oil
product didn't differ that much from
another and so Rockefeller created the
conspiracy with the railroads called the
South improvement company that not only
gave preferential rates to Standard Oil
but at the same time gave punitive rates
to Rockefellers rivals when news of this
leaked ad in western Pennsylvania
Rockefeller was was burned in' and an
effigy there were huge torchlight
parades and towns like Titusville and
Oil City and Franklin and the other
centers of the of the oil region and
there was so much protest that this
conspiracy was disbanded what happened
though was that during that time where
the conspiracy still seemed to be very
much alive Rockefeller took over 22 of
the 26 other refineries in in in
Cleveland because his competitors felt
that they could not possibly compete
with Standard Oil which was in cahoots
with the railroad so it was a very
significant moment it was the first time
that his name appeared in the newspaper
but then even though he was
controversial in the oil industry it was
many many years before the general
public realized that one of the ten
richest and most powerful men in the
United States was this john d
rockefeller who controlled the oil
refining industry he was a very very
shadowy and secretive figure at what age
did he find himself with lots of money
well by the late 1870s even before he
had reached aged forty he controlled
about 90% of all the oil refining in the
United States how old is he there
actually there he's in his 40s that's a
wonderful of photo and one of the
reasons I reproduced it in the book is
that when you look in those eyes you see
this very keen enterprising determined
spirit I felt that I almost had to erase
Brian the image of the old man with the
newsreel cameras because this is someone
who had been I mean just physically tall
and powerful and imposing not this you
know shrunken
man and people were resist by the way
that was a studio portrait from the
1880s a Rockefeller would have been in
his forties now can see and the photo
that he's a lot taller than he looks I
told you know it's interesting he he's
standing there with a top hat and cane
this was a self-made man who had grown
up in rustic areas of upstate New York
look at how dignified and polished
he looks there and you could also see
the tremendously imposing presence you
know people who dealt with him in a
business situation talked about these
eyes these piercing eyes that would just
drill holes through you and William
James said that it was the most
suggestive formidable personality that
he had ever met this was someone who was
a very imposing presence later on he he
becomes this sort of laughing geezer had
the gout dimes and I write about that
and he became a rather colorful
eccentric old man and that's fun what's
this I didn't mean ever up did I want to
draw on the eyes you've got this on the
photo this photo on the cover what how
old was he here he was in his sixties
and I loved that photo because I think
you see in the in the eyes but a frood
canny and rather enigmatic character he
he was gone here he has a rig on he had
lost all of his hair he suffered from
something called alopecia in 1901 he
lost not only all the hair on his head
he lost all body hair and this was a
great tragedy in his life because then
Ida Tarbell came along a year later
did this series portraying him as a
monster and since he was hairless and
suddenly looked old and and ghoulish his
appearance seemed to ratify what she was
saying in the series so the timing was
particularly unfortunate for rockefeller
we've got some a lot of photos we want
to show the audience but before we do
that how hard was it to get these well
the Rockefeller archive Center they're
about three or four thousand photos
there the difficulty was that when he
later in life learned to love the camera
we have hundreds and hundreds of
pictures to choose
from during the earlier years where he
was so publicity-shy I mean during his
active business career he never granted
interviews never allowed himself to be
photographed so that for instance I
couldn't find a single photo of him when
he was in his 30s I had two or three
when he was in his 40s so in the earlier
part of the book we had to make do with
the photos that were did you pick all
these yourself yeah I went through all
the photos I picked them I arranged that
might consider that part of my job as
the author because it's part of the
image of this man that I'm projecting to
the reader before I show the photos are
you this is a full-time job for you
right in these books yes it is how long
have you done I've been doing it now
since the end of 1986 what were you
doing before that I had a long phase
from the time that I left school in 1973
I worked as a freelance magazine and
newspaper writer for about 10 years I
worked for a think tank called the 20th
century fund for about three and a half
years and then I started work on the
house of Morgan where'd you go school I
did a BA in English at Yale College and
then I did an MA in English at Cambridge
University in England now what is it
about writing that you like for me
writing it's it's it's a it's a sensual
pleasure really I think that with any
writer worth his or her salt there's a
kind of almost sublimated sexuality
about it if I can use Freudian language
there's nothing that gives me greater
pleasure than actually stringing words
together and I think that I'm actually I
think this is true of most writers that
we're writing all the time not just when
we're sitting in front of the computer
screen or the typewriter or whatever
what's your daily pattern my daily
pattern is really really kind of a dull
boy I wake up I have breakfast I
exercise to music or National Public
Radio pour a cup of coffee
get a jolt of caffeine flip on the word
processor and
usually work until around 4:30 and if
the phone doesn't ring I'm in absolute
heaven but it usually rings many times
during the day you get blocked at all
now you know I've never suffered from
from writers the book it's really not in
my lexicon because I figured out early
on my own trick for getting out of it
which is as follows I if I can't write
something I suddenly imagined myself
explaining it to a reasonably
intelligent friend if that doesn't work
I imagined arguing the point with the
passionate adversary that usually gets
the juices flowing so I started pacing
my office and carrying on this imaginary
debate but someone who my picture is
very hostile and skeptical about what
I'm saying and then the words with that
anger forget the foe
what does it say about both john d
rockefeller and Henry Flagler that they
paid $300 to substitutes so they didn't
have to fight in the Civil War this is
an interesting story it wasn't unusual
for you know for well-to-do men John he
was well-to-do in his twenties it wasn't
unusual for people to pay a substitute
to JP Morgan did Teddy Roosevelt's
father did I think Grover Cleveland did
there are a lot of different cases
Rockefeller claimed and I think that he
was right that he had you know paid and
outfitted twenty or thirty different
people to to fight what's interesting is
that given the fact that you know he was
so money mad he marries into a family
called the Spellman's who wonderful a
family they were not only ardent
temperance activists but they were
ardent abolitionists who had been
conductors on the Underground Railroad
they'd had Sojourner Truth in the house
and then Rockefeller goes on to found
Spelman College to educate freed female
slaves and so there's no question that
he felt deeply bad abolitionism it may
well have been that he couldn't restrain
these money-making impulses but another
important thing that I explained in the
book is that when he was in his twenties
his father who was a bigamist and had
abandoned the family that John D has to
single-handedly support his
brothers and sisters and his mother over
there you can see the parents on the
left William Avery rockefeller colorful
raffish mountebank we've been in John's
childhood would disappear for weeks or
months that time out on the road selling
snake oil John's John Dee's cunning side
the rascality clearly comes from his
father on the right his mother
Eliza's very strict very pious and all
the thrift discipline industry
religiosity come from the mother so here
you have the product of these crazily
mismatched parents who then produced
quite logically a crazily contradictory
son the father you say had two different
names two different wives two different
families
that's right around 1855 he abandons the
family he will reappear throughout their
lives every year out of the bloom but he
marries a much younger woman who knows
him as dr. William Livingston they're
married for approximately 50 years
behind only during the last two years of
that 50-year marriage does Margaret
Allen Livingston learn that for decades
she has been married to the father of
the richest man in the world I keep
telling people if a novelist had
invented this people would say it was
too preposterous a plot twist and get
rid of it nobody will believe it I was
able to completely reconstruct this
whole implausible story in terms of not
only what happened to the father but
this second marriage but also what his
relationship was with John we also have
the I guess a sister and a brother here
of John the bride here he's with his
elder with his younger brother and
sister he's on the right he's on the
right and then brother William who
became a standard oil executive is on
the on the left
what's interesting about this photo is
that the children look very very grim
and in somber in a way that I think
can't be completely explained by the
photographic methods of the day what was
just taken this was taken in
it would have been around 1852 because
John was on the right there was 13 years
old what's interesting is that from the
photos we can see that he had this
rather grim and somber childhood but in
later years when he reminisced it was
this golden idyllic time the value of
photographs because very often people
tend to sentimentalize or idealize their
their childhood and so the photographic
record speaks often with a kind of
objectivity that the subjects don't
who's this lady this lady is Laura
Celestia Spellman at the time that she
married john d rockefeller her nickname
was SETI
this was 1864 when they got married she
was about 25 years old she was a very
bright lively intelligent young woman
kind of bluestocking she was a
schoolteacher she went to college at a
time when that was extremely rare she
believes strongly in abolitionism and
and temperance she then later on as the
years went by she became an almost
suffocatingly pious lady she loses a lot
of this intellectual vitality that you
see early on and one thing that many
people have speculated and I tend to
suspect that it's true is that as the
drumbeat of criticism against Standard
Oil grew louder that she took refuge in
the church so that she becomes a kind of
unreal in other worldly person who talks
in a very high-flown religious rhetoric
and it's strange that john dee who is
accused of being the greatest corporate
criminal of the age goes home to this
household that is drenched in baptist
piety and feels no discontinuity
whatsoever between what he's doing at
the office and the home atmosphere that
he returns to what would you say that
did let me ask you this way did he do
anything illegal in his life he did a
lot of the things that he did were
certainly unfair iein covered a lot of
correspondence where he was directly
paying off different politicians and at
the time to directly pay off a
politician to kill a piece of
legislation was illegal sometimes they
use different subterfuges and would hire
somebody is
as legal counsel what's interesting is
that Rockefeller often pointed out that
his most of his business career was
played out before the Interstate
Commerce Commission was created in 1887
outlawing railroad rebates and before
the Sherman Act was passed in 1890
outlawing combinations in restraint of
trade but what you see with Standard Oil
is that even when those two landmark
pieces of legislation are enacted the
behavior of the trust really doesn't
doesn't change at all and you can see in
the papers they're just trying to figure
out different ways to circumvent the law
that basically John Dinah's colleagues
regarded government regulators as
nuisances to be bypassed wherever
possible you say that he gave $250,000
in 1896 to the William McKinley campaign
for president right how much money would
that be today oh that would be several
million dollars today he didn't like
politicians he felt that politicians
were basically parasites who would shake
down businessman I mean all of this
bribery he saw as extortion that is the
politicians shaking him down rather than
his paying off the the politicians so
that he had very little interest in
conventional politics I think that he
regarded these payments as yeah
really is a business expense he was
never somebody aside from writing a
cheque who would ever get involved in a
political campaign you know and it's
interesting I think Bryan that if you
look at the late 19th century the people
who were really building up the country
where the business men and and not the
the politicians you know if someone were
to ask you whether you would rather read
a biography of john d rockefeller Andrew
Carnegie let's say rather than a
Rutherford B Heiser Benjamin Harrison or
you know which two were more important I
think we will say Rockefeller and
Carnegie rather than Harrison and hey so
you go through a period in the late 19th
century that is one of tremendous
political squalor partly caused by the
business interests themselves so it was
also not an atmosphere that was likely
to generate a tremendous amount of
respect and the in the business
community weeks
the business community was not directly
responsible for a lot of squalor
I remember tripping across his great one
day when I was at the James Garfield
grave in Cleveland right across the
street there from him what's he doing
being buried in Cleveland when most of
the other families in New York well it's
interesting you know it's interesting
with a lot of people in Cleveland
they're not aware that John Dee moved
there as a teenager's started in
business as a teenage clerk in Cleveland
in the 1850s started Standard Oil there
in 1870 and not only even after he moved
to New York in the early 1880s retained
in a state in Cleveland until the late
nineteen hundreds I'm sorry late
nineteen teens he transferred a lot of
his affection to New York he felt that
he was treated better by politicians in
the press in New York Cleveland really
mishandled Rockefeller because today in
New York City has the cloyster as the
museum modern hard Riverside Church
Rockefeller University with his
Rockefeller institutions that might have
gone to Cleveland if he felt that he had
been treated better by politicians and
press in his own hometown
and so the family gravesite was in in
Cleveland but certainly his son was John
Deere IFL jr. was born in 1874 and so
when he's five or six years old the
family moves to New York so it's not
surprising that by that generation they
feel themselves New Yorkers but for John
D Cleveland it was always like an
unrequited love affair with this city
what did he do about giving his money
away well you know the image of John D
is that he that he made a pile during
this career and then gave away a pile
afterwards if that had been the case you
know that's a cliche the businessman you
know makes a bundle and then sanitizes
the fortune by giving it to good works
but makes John D so much more
fascinating and enigmatic and compelling
of characters that he was making money
as fast as he could from the time he was
a teenager and giving it away as fast as
he could he was a Baptist he was tithing
as a teenager by the time he's in his
early forties right he's creating
Spellman college in it
then Spellman seminary to educate
emancipated female slaves by the time
he's in his early 50s he's
single-handedly creating the University
of Chicago but time he's in his early
sixties he's single-handedly creating
the Rockefeller Institute for medical
research today Rockefeller University
first major Medical Research Institute
in the United States is creating general
education board largest educational
foundation in the country he's creating
huge philanthropic institutions
throughout his career not publicizing
them and it's clear from his papers that
if anything he found it very distasteful
the idea of publicizing what he was
doing and frankly for selfish reasons he
didn't want to publicize it because when
there would be in the newspaper an
article about one of his large requests
he would receive on average fifty
thousand letters soliciting money within
a 30-day period after the appearance of
such articles his philanthropic advisor
Frederick T Gates said Mr Rockefeller
was stalked and hounded like a wild
animal everywhere he went everybody from
the most noble to the most ignoble were
soliciting him for money how about his
children how did he deal with money with
the kids well you know it's interesting
he being a very puritanical sword he was
haunted by the corrupting influence of
wealth so that even though the children
grew up on these estates in certain
cases of several thousand acres he had
them in very strict allowances my most
interesting details that I discovered
during the research was the john d
rockefeller jr. who was the only son the
youngest of four children said that
until the age of 8 he wore only female
clothes and the interviewer this was a
private interview the interviewer was
said to him oh you only were female
cause was that just because the style of
the time is that little boys you know
wore dresses he said oh no no you don't
understand
we all wore hand-me-downs and the three
older siblings were all girls and so the
hand-me-downs that were coming down to
me we're all you know it's dresses and
skirts this is how frugally they were
brought up so that John Day tried to
recreate his own threadbare child
hood with the children even though he
was on route to becoming the richest man
in the world because he wanted them to
learn the value of dollar you know and
he looked at all these other children of
the the Grandy's of the Gilded Age and
he saw them you know becoming
philanderers and alcoholics and
everything else and he was determined
that these children were going to be
thrifty and responsible and true
remarkable extent he succeeded because
you see a lot of famous families burn
out after a generation into the
Rockefellers have managed to go on being
a significant force in business politics
and philanthropy in this country what's
the story of the widow Backus the widow
back is this was a story that was given
currency by Henry Demarest Lloyd and Ida
Tarbell the great muckraking critics who
claimed that back in the late 1870s in
Cleveland
that Rockefeller had taken over a
lubricant plant owned by the widow
Backus and had cheated her when Ida
Tarbell repeated this this was a very
trivial episode in the history of
Standard Oil which had a global oil
monopoly but it had a very potent
appealed to the public imagination
imagine mr. Rockefeller was so sadistic
and so ruthless that he was cheating
this poor Widow in fact he had offered
her a very very fair fair price and it
was later documented that in fact he had
not cheated her when the time came for
Rockefeller to publish his own random
reminiscences in 1908 he devoted
probably more space to the widow Backus
story than any other because this
incident had had such a hold on the
popular imagination that he himself said
if I crushed a poor defenseless Widow
then I really must be a very terrible
human being and so he spent on what was
really almost microscopic transaction
and standard all history spent several
pages in his book defending his behavior
it was one of the few things that I did
Tarbell really got wrong it was amazing
how much she got right but that one she
did a disservice which one of the
residents of the Rockefellers is this
this is John D's seniors house called
chi ket he had four states this was on
his estate in the kanto hills of
westchester north of New York City and
that house is today open to the public
now it's about 40 or 50 rooms which
sounds fairly impressive but if one
thinks of the Newport cottages of the
day and is very you know pretentious and
other elephantine places this was a
surprisingly modest place for the
world's richest man to live and it shows
that he was generally a known
ostentatious person the only and I
should point out it was surrounded by
3,500 acres and several dozen miles of
carriage trails that he had personally
laid out so that the grounds are
beautiful but he was much more
interested in the in the grounds than
the interior of the the house he was he
was a very West evangelical Christian
and for him I think it was rather pagan
and idolatrous to have a lot of
expensive paintings in a big fancy house
and ballroom that was not his style he
did have a nine hole golf course he had
his own private golf course at each of
his houses that was arguably his
greatest indulgence if you were to total
up everything that he was worth today
what would that figure be okay his net
worth peaked in 1913 at nine hundred
million dollars which if you translate
into contemporary dollars is thirteen
billion which does not sound like very
much but doesn't begin to tell the whole
story for a number of reasons
he had 900 million dollars in 1913 the
entire federal budget in 1913 was 715
million dollars so he could have
personally paid for every federal
employee in expense and had money left
to spare him the total accumulated
national debt that year was 1.2 billion
so he could have retired three quarters
of the total national debt Rockefeller
made the statement in 1917 he had given
away so much money he said that if he
had kept the money by 1917 he would have
been worth 3 billion which would be more
than 30 billion today and would put him
in second place behind Bill Gates but
Bill Gates's wealth only represents
one-half of 1% of the gross national
product Rockefellers wealth represented
two and a half percent of the gross
national product which is why
people claim with some justice that john
d rockefeller was the richest man in
american history his grandson
Winthrop went on to be governor of
Arkansas his grandson
my grandson Nelson went on to be
governor of New York and vice president
at States his great-grandson went on to
be United States Senator you said he
didn't like politicians what any of
those men been in those positions that
they didn't have his money I don't know
it's a fair question one of the
interesting things is how the
Rockefeller attitude towards politics
changes because when the federal
government brings the big antitrust suit
against and at the time Teddy Roosevelt
Rockefeller has a very very defiant and
rather contemptuous attitude toward
cabman his son john d rockefeller jr. is
very much inspired I think by the
atmosphere of Woodrow Wilson is
interested in public-private
partnerships he buys up the grand tetons
valley and gives it to the federal
government for what is today you know
arguably the most glorious National Park
in the United States ditto for Acadia
National Park up in Maine and then you
actually have Nelson running for office
and becoming governor of Arkansas
Winthrop becoming a governor of I'm
sorry Nelson the camp governor of New
York weather became governor of Arkansas
when Nelson first entertained the notion
of becoming governor of New York
Thomas II do we said he couldn't be
elected dog catcher in New York the in
Rockefeller name was considered that
much of a liability so that while the
wealth was enormous Lee advantageous the
the name itself was both a help and a
hinderence because the Rockefeller name
historically had inspired a lot of
hostility what if this book is new you
mentioned the Inglis interview before
what else did you find that that they
hadn't been done before one of the
things that I did is that all sorts of
things that happened at Standard Oil
which john d rockefeller claimed had
never been had never happened or if they
had happened they had been carried out
by overly zealous underlings i was able
to directly connect him to all of these
various nefarious activities that went
on at Standard Oil to his credit I was
able to correct connect him much more
directly with all of his great
philanthropic enterprises because a lot
of people felt that he was
detached from them whereas in fact he
was very actively shaping and and
monitoring them I think perhaps the
single most important thing that I did
in this book was that took somebody who
was considered inhuman and turned him
into a human being he was a deeply
flawed human being but I think that I
bring him at least I hope I bring him to
life on the on the page because he had
been seen as almost a kind of malevolent
automaton throughout his life and he was
a very if you read the earlier
biographies
he's almost missing from his own
biography so ghostly he's so elusive so
I have addition to a lot of analysis and
information I introduced hundreds of
anecdotes in the book just to try to
bring him alive as a person because in
his time and people don't know this in
his day he was considered not only the
richest American he was considered one
of the greatest and most original and
most eccentric personalities that the
United States had ever produced and that
fascinated main I hope that I catch that
you have a picture here of him sitting
with a couple little girls yeah there's
a great guy ganders he loved children
you know one of the reasons I have
summoning we have a hundred five photos
in the book and one reason is that you
see all the different expressions all
the different faces of john d
rockefeller people tend to see him in a
very one-dimensional fashion when in
fact he was a very very complicated man
there are no two decades of his life
where he consecutive decades where he
looks the same his channel Rogers her
yeah he was great friends with with Will
Rogers in full Rogers came up with a lot
of funny lines he used to golf together
and Will Rogers one day I said to
Toronto feller I'm after Rockefeller
beat him at golf Will Rogers said to me
gee Dijon I'm glad I lost you in golf
the last time I beat you the price of
gasoline went up a dime another time
Bill Rogers God turned the tables on
John Dave is a famous picture of Will
Rogers giving John Dee a die
rather than taking one and Rockefeller
sort of sitting there with this comical
shocked expression on his face he loved
Will Rogers remember Will Rogers humor
very kind of dry Midwestern sort of
humor was exactly Rockefellers own human
he used to every day in the newspapers
avidly look for Will Rogers jokes didn't
smoke didn't drink didn't swear no
didn't go to the theatre didn't go to
the to the Opera this was the last
Puritan and I might have though a little
little it seems how did contact with
everything else did and here's the
picture I showed it earlier that when he
was running around in the countryside in
the car he liked to explain this is very
very interesting Rockefellers wife who
had been a sort of professional
interlude for the last 10 to 20 years of
her life after she dies in 1915 John D
lives another 22 years there's no
evidence during all the years that his
wife was an invalid that he ever cheated
on her he seems to have been a model
husband one of many contradictions of of
the man and model husband the second she
dies he never has shown interest in
women he's suddenly surrounded by women
oh yeah there's his wife in a wheelchair
well she was confined to well chair
during the last few years of her life as
soon as she dies he develops a real
roving eye and he has this afternoon
ritual where he goes out with a party of
people in this large touring car he
always sits tightly wedged between two
bucks and women on either side he has a
blanket that he draws over their laps
and up to their necks and his hot did
she fingers would stray under the
blanket and so Rockefeller lived his
adolescence in his last year is when
he's a young man he looks very old and
serious when he's an old man he looks
rather joined II and
and young so he seems to keep getting
younger and even slightly silly as he
gets out how did you learn that last the
law the terrible actually there was a
rather gossipy memoir that was written
by his chief gardener because when they
would go out on these afternoon drives
the gardener would often be driving the
second car and he said one day they
pulled up at a stop sign and this young
woman who was sitting next to
Rockefeller left out of the the back
seat and came running back to his car
and she's got in the car and she said
that old rooster I'll never sit next to
him again and apparently Rockefeller had
been trying to feel her up during the
the ride one last little connecting
point here that James Thomas fleckner's
father who was on this show is right
here like that Simon Flexner he was the
first director of the Rockefeller
Institute for medical research today the
Rockefeller University and when that was
started in 1901 it was a very very novel
concept Rockefeller himself suggested it
it was novel because there was no
Institute devoted purely to medical
research and at the time the idea of
paying scientists to sit around and just
daydream and come up with discoveries
was considered something not only
brand-new but rather quixotic and even
doomed to failure but but Simon Flexner
very quickly developed a treatment a
serum for for meningitis and it's been
one of the great success stories not
only over the Rockefeller family but of
American medicine any plans for another
book already for you I think the next
one will have to be shorter I'm a bit
exhausted I've done published three
monsters in a ten year period plus
whether the Warburg's in the house of
Morgan are still very much in paperback
and then I did a short collection of
essays last year called the the death of
the banker so I think the next project
will be something shorter and more in
the area of instant gratification what
was the most fun about doing this book
the most fun about doing it I think was
just penetrating all of his disguises
you know that there are certain
biographical subjects who seem to live
for their biographers they record all
their thoughts and then there
maddening people who live in order to
torment and frustrate their Bogg refers
and John Dee was the supreme example of
this type of secretive person and I
don't know that I penetrated all of his
disguises for his mysteries but enough
so that I felt that I really created a
fresh portrait of man where'd you get
the title title Titan well you know
there was a Dreiser novel called the
Titan I like the sort of novelistic ring
of it I also wanted a title that would
suggest business it suggests the
gigantic scope but would not tell you
whether it was a flattering or
unflattering vision of the man so I was
looking for something that was
deliberately ambiguous and then also I
liked from a design standpoint a
five-letter title I pictured it the way
it was of these sort of bold letters
leaping off the page like them and this
is the cover of the book Titan the life
of john d rockefeller senior our guest
has been ron chernow thank you very much
pleasure to run